[Music]
this is a holdup news just shoot me
shuto submitted by filipino egg world's
yeah yeah lumpia don't you dare that's
what she said
boyfriend stages terrifying robbery
prank to propose to his girlfriend
leaving her cowering in tears oh my god
that's one [ __ ] dog why but she said yes
but she still married him that doesn't
make it better that's not a good button
cuz there's a lot of these like proposal
things where it's like oh my god I
thought you died and he's just like oppa
William do but someone actually died
though oh yeah the woman to do that like
go over there water some water ya know
it's like why he said he [ __ ] drowned
okay somebody explain that story real
quick I know it went you like a like
like some hotel room right underwater
resort yeah something like that so he
wouldn't have yeah he swam down Lam down
without school his note said something
like I don't know how long I can hold my
breath but there's not enough breaths in
the world to tell you how much I love
you tighter rope Raymond Giuliano this
was originally in 2017 but since gone
viral
Raymond Giuliano decided it was a great
idea to fake the armed robbery while
they were at a liquor store picking up
beer with his then-girlfriend and his
girlfriend was in on it to rob this no I
don't know the girlfriend when he was
proposing to who's a store owner in on
it
god I hope so fun fact the clerk was
actually not in on it so the couple is
out there paying for their beer and then
this guy in a beanie comes up he
brandishes a fake gun points it at the
clerk and demands they put cash into his
duffel bag to which the clerk does put
cash in a duffle bag
we have so much fake money here
wait continue this is great a lot more
this already Clarke turns to the couple
one says I think I just got robbed to
which the prankster replies did you what
of the prank robber guy tells him to go
to the back tell him go to back the
store back back back back back get to
the back of the store the girlfriend
panicking as she should be wants to walk
past the refrigerators and out of the
store like a normal sane person
but being the boyfriend he is he didn't
want his great prank to like go and get
ruined like that so he actually tells
her no stay on the floor stay on the
floor
Sullivan she's obviously freaking out
right so then the robber starts going
into a moral battle saying like you know
he has to provide for his children for
Christmas this is why we don't monologue
for Robert again yeah he just says that
he has to figure things out he starts
just going like you know very
sympathetic crowd I guess starts asking
the couple of their kids to which the
girlfriend actually terrified says I
have three kids and he asked her a lot
of their ages and then she replies or
here the husband replies 14-6 and - and
then - which the robber goes to the
boyfriend what and you're not even
married man I don't see a ring Robert
I'm so good at improvising and then the
robber pulls out I'm a shooter sorry
gives it to mr. Raymond Giuliano says
well what are you waiting for
so I will you marry me - which of course
Chanel who's the girlfriend [ __ ]
tears says are you serious yeah and then
she says yes and then hahaha she
exclaims huh I'm gonna kill you this is
so crazy and then she actually insisted
that she actually they actually
purchased the beer that they're visually
came in to purchase so they bought the
beer it was the whole thing was a hoot
and there's a hand
some money towards the [ __ ] conductor
look bad for Volvo can't believe that
they did include the [ __ ] cashier in
on this [ __ ] can you hit the sign alarm
and stuff another please yeah dude holy
[ __ ]
so there is just kidding there is a
happy ending so mr. Juliano did feel bad
and actually proposed a second time with
more of a man well what about nobody
said in my circle anything yeah I don't
care what she thinks anymore and that's
just [ __ ] loss for words I mean did
they leave the cash with the register in
the register like and then we got our
money from the register to go on our
honeymoon
best [ __ ] robbery ever they [ __ ]
get away with the money and then just as
a prank we're not actually robbing you
but wait wait give me my money back
like I'm sure the money came bad and the
clerk just laughed it off I don't know I
wouldn't I'd be like yo dude I'm
pressing charges
holy [ __ ] emotional trauma lawsuit right
there yeah but yeah he brought her to a
romantic trip to New York City and
that's that's not really romantic this
is the second time right you Duke region
you a second time okay yeah yeah they
went to bed with the busted Bastin New
York right that's why right is the
romantic New York way all right what you
say is romantic nobody who said I'm an
article an article says yeah but they
yeah they had a more romantic proposal
in New York yes because a more romantic
trip like he took he did the whole
shebang right horse who robbed the
second liquor store they had a massage
they had a that's not romantic well why
didn't he do that in the first place
because he felt bad oh no no he should
have done it in the first place all and
then they have the third wheel which is
a store click with them I felt bad for
you too so
he's just like that just like I don't
wanna be here I think this is one of the
cases where in his head he thought he
was a genius and then as they unfolded
he was like old proves that people are
talking stupid it's not okay oh yeah
what the honey man but she still took
him I think she's his keeper keeper for
this guy but like dude man you just
couple better hope that they never
actually get robbed ever again in their
entire life because they're kind of like
that's when they start their prank vs.
prank channel what you're saying is that
this is the future influenced a couple
pretty now like subscribe to me on I
subscribed so what are you guys gonna
make your proposals elaborate elaborate
what if this is what kids it'll ever is
like I think sharing it on social media
is cool but I'm not doing like a putting
a full production behind it I think it's
kind of like you lose for me I for me
personally I wanted to just be me and
her that's fair maybe set up us hidden
camera yeah all those things and then
maybe have a friend thing afterwards
because I think the proposal is a very
should be very just very intimate yeah I
don't mind snapping a picture and show
Vanessa Graham maybe have Ryan hide in a
bush with like a super telephoto lens
wait oh don't worry about it something
I've heard though from I guess some
girls that I've talked to you they've
been like yeah I don't like the whole
idea of like a public / proposal because
it's so much pressure on the girl likes
a yes or a No like I don't know that I'd
ever want to make my significant other
feel that kind of pressure is the same
[ __ ] like with the high school prom
poses if I was like the whole auditorium
it's like she wants to say no and then
she just leaves yeah that's like I can't
we had a choreographed dance yeah
are those still in style people in high
school lettuce was a thing at my
school's ever and plane by over with a
sign in the back you get asked to prom
and stuff like that or did you all of us
dude I think my sister or somebody was
like they got an orange in their locker
and ten they turned she turned it over
and it was like aren't you glad my money
level at my school I think sorry I asked
you the ayat I asked a girl to prom she
flew in a plane he was flying my video
teacher was a radio DJ over at UCI 4k
UCI and I have her listen in on it and
then the moment the song played I showed
up at her house with a bunch of flowers
and [ __ ] Wow I'm gonna ask her to prom
then and then later on she reciprocated
and asked me to her prom oh it's so cute
the teacher had me leave the class and
they're like yeah we one of your
textbooks is like the same teacher your
textbooks on fire so they send over the
back of the school where they had the
textbook thing and they're like yeah
there's a problem with your textbook so
I was like I turned it all my textbooks
probably and then I come back and our
our classroom is a studio and I'd look
around open the door and there's just
[ __ ] posters like posters everywhere
I just say shun dude for all shouting
new information and I followed the path
and the murder situation we had this
little studio it was written in blood we
had this little studio and they had a
spotlight so someone was behind the
light panel turned it on and she's
standing underneath that's cool fancy
ice fountain vallye kids over there
[Laughter]
I think I think I'm more on board with
the organ low-class [ __ ] I appreciate
the pun though you know it's [ __ ]
funny though obvious always hilarious
about the promposals would you [ __ ]
see some dude walking with like [ __ ]
hell of flowers it should try to be all
stealthy [ __ ] high school just like
trying to be like putting it in their
[ __ ] locker and stuff and just like
bro and then oh my god so in college
this organization that as a part of has
this one event where everybody dresses
up and everybody does promposals for
that and it's like dude you guys are in
college sounds like a call yeah but I'm
like cuz because when I was in it did
you do blood sacrifices that's why his
name was written from all right but when
I was in it we didn't do those blood
sighs a it's lame now but it was cool
and he loved it no we actually didn't do
that sort of stuff and then all of a
sudden after I had left everyone started
doing the dude proposals like Oh will
you go to this event with me and I'm
like and it's just like why are you guys
making such a big deal it's not prom
it's the people who couldn't grow though
they didn't have a high school phase
near there so this is their chance yeah
doing it in college or just those old
people that complain about young people
now yep your damn kids old now I was
great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]